(MUFFLED APPLAUSE, CHEERS)
HARRY HAFT: It keeps
going on in my head...
and I can't stop it.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
EMORY ANDERSON:
Harry Haft, I'm a journalist.
I covered your fight.
I'm interested in your story.
Everybody knows my story.
I'm the survivor of Auschwitz.
You fight until one man
can no longer get up.
(BELL DINGS)
GUARD: On the left!
Hands up! Hands up.
My girl from back home,
she doesn't know that I'm alive.
But if my name is
in the papers...
I wanna fight Marciano.
I will plaster your story
all over the East Coast.
It says that you made a deal
to survive by fighting.
You're a traitor!
You think Leah's gone?
I hope she's alive,
and we'll keep looking for her.
I have to be famous
across America.
Enough with the glamour shots,
Rita Hayworth.
Come on, get in here.
CHARLIE GOLDMAN:
Marciano's big hay hits harder.
You were taught wrong
from the beginning.
I'll give you two days training.
Why would you help me win?
Win?
Boychick, I'm just giving you
a chance to lose
with a little dignity.
I fought for her.
And that was the only reason
for-- for fighting.
SPEAKER: Six million
of our people are dead.
Why did you survive
if not to live?
MIRIAM WOFSONIKER: I've heard
every imaginable awful thing.
You can talk to me.
Why does this God
ask so much of us?
I didn't want fear
in your heart.
(GRUNTS)
Who deserves to have
that kind of darkness
inside of their children?!
His life... or yours.
HARRY: These are the choices
we made every day,
choices made when you remember
that you once had a family.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
ANNOUNCER: The survivor
of Auschwitz!